ap
après cinq semaines d'interruption les
conversations dit d'evian ont repris au
château de lugrin tous voisins cette
fois on a donc vu reparaître transporté
par hélicoptère
monsieur belkacem krim à la tête de la
délégation du fln et monsieur louis joxe
chargé de diriger les débats du côté
français les délégations aborder la
discussion par la recherche d'une
méthode de travail mais ce débat de
procédure est parsemé d'obstacles
l'amérique vient de rééditer l'exploit
du commandant shepard second cosmonautes
virgil grissom est entré dans la capsule
spatiale d'une nouvelle fusée redstone
pour faire un nouveau bond dans le
cosmos à plus de 8000 kilomètres à
l'heure la fusée est monté jusqu'à 190
km pour retomber à 488 km de distance
la caméra a pu saisir l'instant où la
capsule s'est détachée de son support
pour tomber dans l'atmosphère
voyage a duré seize minutes
un porte-avions croisette à l'endroit
prévu pour la mairie singes et ses
hélicoptères ont rapidement découvert la
capsule qu'il devait récupérer par
malheur le relevage a été une première
fois manqué et cette erreur a eu comme
résultat la perte de la capsule sombré
par 500 mètres de fond et un d'un fort
c'est pour virgin les sables
m
on pouvait redouter que l'agitation
entreprise par le président bourguiba au
début de juillet produisent des
incidents on sait maintenant ce qui en
est résulté
en donnant un tour aigu à ses
revendications sur la base de bizerte
occupée selon des conventions régulière
par la france celui qu'on donnait pour
un homme politique avisé et prudent est
arrivé au drame
on sait ce qu'est be there un goulet 3
qui mène de la mer au lac intérieur rade
magnifique est sûre on pourrait évoluer
tout une flamme
puis une ville établi sur les bords du
boulet et qui a donné son nom à
l'ensemble
enfin la base navale créé par la france
au centre de la méditerranée la position
de bizerte est primordiale puisqu'elle
commandes de détroit de sicile
cette importance a suscité le destin de
bizerte où les installations de la base
en noir sur la carte sont dispersés sur
les rives du lac
ces installations en dehors même de
l'amirauté et des poids de mouillage des
bâtiments comportent tous les services
annexes d'import atelier à saint magasin
caserne hôpital et un aérodrome dont la
piste devait être allongée de 2 à 3
mètres
ce projet monsieur bourguiba le
transforma en défi il décida de bloquer
la base de bizerte des milliers de
volontaires civils requis par le néo
destour commencé à creuser des tranchées
à établir des barrages
interrompant ainsi la libre circulation
entre les services de la base répartis
autour du lac
autour de l'aérodrome on est habitant
réseau de tranchées et des emplacements
pour l'installation de mortiers et de
canon
l'épreuve de force déjà ce discernait
l'opinion tunisienne chaque jour chauffé
par une propagande incendiaires suivez
le chemin dangereux tracée par son chef
et l'on en arrive à une manifestation
organisée devant l'ambassade de france
ou même les femmes enrégimentés va
prêter un premier concours avant d'être
employé comme on devait le voir plus
tard aux barricades
rené souvent de province éloignée
d'autres volontaires très jeune pour le
plus grand nombre est parfaitement
encadré se met alors en marche sur
viseur pour achever le blocus
il n'était pas question pour les
français de céder sous la menace et les
positions de combat prises par les
unités de l'armée tunisienne et les
volontaires armés qu'on lui avait juin
confirmait la volonté tunisienne
d'engager par les armes
ce que monsieur bourguiba non mais déjà
la bataille de bizerte
un avion français et essuyé bientôt le
feu des tunisiens mais quatre heures
devait passer et de nouveaux tirs se
succéder avant que l'amiral anne en chef
de la baz décide de répondre
oui
du porte avions à rallonge croisant au
large les premiers avions étaient alors
dépêché pour dégager les abords de
l'aérodrome
puis nous approche de l'amirauté la
cimenterie utilisée par les troupes
tunisienne comme base d'actions était
neutralisée
il restait à dégager les accès de la
base et assurer la libre circulation
dans le pool est barré par les tunisiens
c'est ce que devait accomplir les unités
de parachutistes
mais
la libération se terminait par un
nettoyage des traces ou des isolés ou
des bandes plus ou moins contrôlés tiré
du haut des immeubles
le soir tout était fini on pouvait
dénombrer le matériel de toutes
provenances pris aux tunisiens
e
l'amiral a man s'est replacé les
couleurs tunisiennes sur des bâtiments
officiels
au même instant le conseil de sécurité
écouter le délégué français monsieur
armand bérard
aucune puissance ne ressent plus
douloureusement que la france les
événements aussi regrettable qu graves
sur lequel le conseil porte aujourd'hui
son attention et dont la responsabilité
n'incombe en aucune manière à mon pays
le gouvernement français a déjà marqué
dans les communications faites par le
chargé d'affaires de france le 13 et le
16 juillet qu'une solution au problème
de bizet ne saurait être recherchée dans
une atmosphère de passion ni sous la
menace de manifestations populaires
si au contraire la situation redevenait
normale sans menaces ni mise en demeure
une réponse serait adressée au message
que le président bourguiba à permettre
au général de gaulle 7 juillet puis
monsieur mongi slim donner la version
tunisienne de la faire elle propose des
négociations pour un cessez le feu qui
aux yeux du gouvernement tunisien ne
peut être acceptable que si le principe
de l'évacuation définitive et immédiate
est acquise en même temps par conséquent
sur le président la note a été rejetée
pour des raisons de forme aussi bien que
pour des raisons de forme
l'arrêt des hostilités permettrait
d'enterrer les cadavres
le drame avait fait 700 morts il
permettrait de rétablir l'électricité et
l'eau que les parachutistes distribués
par les moyens du bord il permettrait de
rendre son visage à bizet
mais monsieur bourguiba croyait-il dire
si vrai ventes ayant consciemment
préparer lancée et allumer ce conflit il
parlait de cette guerre absurde de
bizerte
[Musique]